未来10年
普通家庭孩子选什么专业和行业最吃香
AI正在淘汰大批重复岗位
而15规划也早已划清国家未来核心赛道
只顾眼前盲目报考
等到2030年毕业
大概率岗位过剩
求职无门
20天讲透志愿填报的一切
今天一条视频给你讲
透到2030年毕业
能稳稳站上时代风口的十个行业
50个专业正式概前
请大家把报道打在公屏上
你有没有想过我们现在最离不开的是什么
从日常的衣食住行
再到最前沿的deep si克人形机器人
最基础的永远是能源
无论是你洗澡做饭还是AI对话互动
背后支持这一切的就是各种能源
25年全社会用电量首次突破10万万亿千瓦时
居全球第一
而且还在稳步增长
甚至这几个月油价一涨
导致各种化工原材料紧缺
全球都扛不住
所以能源行业不仅不会过时
反而会越来越重要
对应专业呢有能源与动力工程
石油工程
核工程与核技术
这些属于传统的能源方向
新能源方向包括电气工程及其自动化
新能源科学工程
储能科学工程
氢能科学工程
新能源材料与器件
还有化学
化工的电化学方向
很多人觉得传统能源没
其实这恰恰相反
煤炭石油电力是国家经济的命脉
必须牢牢掌握在自己手里
所以这些行业里基本就只有央国企
向国家电网
国能集团
中核集团这些顶尖的央国企
本科起步12万
硕士15万
吃住基本全包
六险两金
交的最多
稳定性更深
没得话说
新能源则是当下和未来的绝对风口
还有国家双碳政策加持
毕业能够去比亚迪未来理想
这些车企或者宁德时代亿维锂能
兴旺达
这电池企业年薪二三十万很正常
不管AI时代怎么发展
能源行业永远是最稳的能源
有了接下来就需要芯片这个大脑
为啥这些年国家一直强调芯片要独立自主
因为芯片就是AI时代的算力核心
手机要用芯片
机器人需要芯片
AI更是离不开芯片
咱们被卡脖子最狠的地方就是这
所以实物五规划
把集成电路列为六大新兴支柱产业之首
就是为解决芯片卡脖子问题
实现全链条的自主可控
对应的专业主要有微电子科学工程
集成电路设计与集成系统
集成电路科学工程
电子科学技术
电子封装技术
电子信息工程
很多人只知道IIC设计工资高
但实际上整各产业链都缺人
从芯片设计
晶圆制造
封装测试
工艺开发
再到上游材料
都有大量人才的缺口
985名校硕博可以去华为
海思寒武纪做IC设计
起薪三四十万很常见
但学历不够怎么办呢
本科大多可以去中芯国际
华虹市南威长江存储
长鑫存储
这些芯片厂做工艺工程师
设备工程师
封装测试工程师
年包也有个15到25万
工作相对稳定
想学芯片的
首先冲着28所国家示范性微电子学院
尤其是前九所
那这么多高科技怎么才能做出来
说到底靠的还是这第三个行业
新材料
很多人总说生化环材四大天坑
但材料从来没有真正量过
房地产火的时候
建筑材料吃香
芯片火的时候
半导体材料车厢
新能源火的时候
电池材料车厢
所有行业都离不开
25年
我国新材料总产值突破了8.2万亿元
连续十几年保持两位数增长
这些年不管是造芯片用的半导体硅片
光刻胶
火箭上的耐高温合金
碳纤维复合材料
新能源车上的锂离子电池
这些高端制造背后拼的就是材料本身的突破
如果想毕业了
站在风口
可以选新能源材料与器件
电子芯一些材料
光电信息材料
器件和材料
智能技术
这些新兴专业
不过最好还是选择基础的材料类专业
比如材料科学工程
材料物理
材料化学
打牢基础后再细分专业
不至于一道路走到黑
读研优先考虑进高分子材料
稀有金属材料
超导材料
半导体材料
航空航天
复合材料
这些前沿的方向
毕业去宁德时代
比亚迪
中芯国际
中国航八宝武钢铁
万华化学
这大厂研发电池隔膜
半导体硅片
碳纤维高温合金
本科12到20万
硕士能有个20到35万
有了能源芯片和材料
接下来就是把他们真正变成生产力的
先进制造业国家
现在要的就是能够解决各种卡脖子问题的
硬核技术
半导体设备
人形机器人
新型电池
这些方面都要有突破
所以15规划
要构建以先进制造业为骨干的现代化产业体系
那对口专业有机械工程
机械设计制造及其自动化
机械电子工程
智能制造
工程自动化
机械工程
聚生智能等等
很多家长担心毕业去打螺丝
其实操控机器打螺丝
甚至专科也能有出路
可以去做设备维护
拿个五六千也不成问题
本科在二三线城市起薪也有个七八千
要是98521的硕博毕业去搞研发
二三十万很正常
这行很认学历和经验
虽然没法和互联网这种新兴行业比
但各类国企私企都大量招人
毕业不愁找不到工作
不过加班倒班出差可能会比较多
第五个行业人工智能
很多人觉得AI来了
程序员马上就要被替代
计算机专业是不是不行了
恰恰相反
AI越发展
越需要扎实的计算机人才打底
2025年
国家正式开展人工智能加行动
到2030年
智能终端普及率要超过9%
十035年全面步入智能社会
制造金融医疗教育等等
各行各业都需要大量的人工智能人才
这背后是10万亿级的产业风口
也是真金白的就业机会
但千万别用AI火就无脑冲人工智能专业啊
行业没问题
专业却未必适合所有人
因为真正的AI本质是计算机
自动化和统计的深度融合
普通院校本科阶段就只能学个皮毛
大厂的AI算法岗
基本只要985的硕博
千万别头脑一热就进去当炮灰
对大多数人而言
还是学计算机科学与技术
软件工程
自动化
统计学
应用统计学
数据科学与大数据技术
这专业最稳进可攻
AI退可守
本行未来能走的路子最宽
大学里啊
别光听课
课余多刷刷力扣的
打打比赛
做做项目
有空多实习
只要有真技术
也照样能够进字节
阿里腾讯这些互联网大厂
搞大模型算法或者A型的开发
年薪起步三五十万
第六个行业低空经济
国家已经把低空经济确立为战略性新兴产业
民航局还专门成立低空安全司
定了深圳
杭州等六个低空经济试点城市
布局了一整条产业链
从飞行器本体
飞控系统
通信导航
低空调度再到物流巡检
应急安防全都有对口专业呢有低空技术与工程
飞行器
适航技术
通信工程
交通运输
遥感科学与技术
导航工程
这些专业毕业了
不仅可以进航天科技
航天科工
中航工业之传统方向的航空央国企
从事大飞机火箭卫星的研发制造工作
也能去大江一航
莱斯低空经济企业搞无人机平台
低空物流航线规划调度系统
但得注意啊
这是一个纯粹的交叉领域
学计算机
电子信息自动化
机械电气材料这些工科同样也能够入行
如果你是那种数学物理特别强的顶尖学霸
那就很适合这第七个行业
量子科技与前沿通信
量子科技正在从实验室研发转向产业化落地
一旦实现技术突破
产业前景非常广阔
15规划把量子科技列为前沿科技公关重点
到2030年大概率也是万亿级赛道
对口专业有物理学
应用物理学
数学与应用数学
光电信息科学工程
量子信息科学
通信工程
信息工程和测控技术与仪器等等
这行门槛确实很高
基本都要读硕读博
本科建议先学通信工程或者电子信息研究生
再转量子方向
通信本身属于电子信息大类
本科课程和计算机微电子光电高度重合
就业很灵活
未来即可以继续深造研究量子领域
也推进互联网大厂
通信企业
芯片企业或者科研院所
说完了这些硬核科技
咱再来聊聊每个人都逃不过的生老病死
第八个行业
医疗健康
但还是有银发红利
人老了最舍得花钱的地方是哪
就是医疗和保健康复
2030年
我国人均均预期寿命会达到79岁
健康产业规模也会迎来大规模增长
15规划提出了
医疗资源更多下沉到社区和县城
那么对口专业有临床医学
口腔医学
护理学
还有生物医学工程
说实话学医确实辛苦
本科5年起步
后面还有漫长的读研
读博和规培之路
差不多十多年才能基本稳定下来
而且现在三甲医院基本只要名校硕博
性价比已经越来越低了
但不管经济好坏
有病了总得治吧
而且越老越吃香
未来医疗和养老需求越来越多
稳定性肯定是靠谱的
还有很多人担心AI会不会取代医生
我说白了AI最多是辅助诊断提高效率
但根本没法代替医生去和病人沟沟通下
最终的判断
如果觉得学医太苦呢
生物医学工程也是不错的选择
硕博毕业可以进迈瑞联影
这些医疗器械大厂搞研发或者销售
未来医疗器械国产替代空间巨大
没医生那么累
还能拿高薪
除了身体健康
也别忘了大环境的安全
这就是第九个行业
国家与公共安全
这两年国际局势大家都看到了
各种冲突不断
国家和社会保持和谐稳定
压力越来越大
这个赛道的重要性不言而喻
对口的专业有军警类
航空航天类和兵器类专业毕业直接进部队
公安局或者军工类的央国企
这不仅是一份养家糊口的工作
更是实实在在的保家卫国
社会地位非常高
但注意啊
军警类专业报考有严格的政审体检和体测要求
航空航天类和冰器类专业多在国防七子
兵工七子开设
要真的读到不太容易
那文科生是不是彻底没机会了
当然不是最后一个行业
文化产业
这就是最适合文科生的黄金赛道
很多人以为AI来了
但内容行业最先受到冲击
但AI降低的是创作门槛
真正有创意的人
价值反而更高
实物规划强调文化和科技深度融合
短视频游戏
文旅沉浸式演出
微短剧都在爆发
哪吒电影和黑神话
悟空游戏的全球爆火
都证明文化方面的需求越来越热
对口专业呢有新闻学
传播学
广告学
网络与新媒体
数字媒体艺术
广播电视编导
毕业可以去各大内容平台或者运营公司
做内容运营策划
干得好
年薪二三十万不是问题
文科不是不行了
而是要把创意做成落地的产品
做出有价值的内容
这才是真正的护城河
OK如果这期视频对你有帮助
欢迎点赞收藏转发
我是空框
让我们下期视频再见